these children figure out within minutes
that they can watch films on this
e-reader and not only read digital books
some of the biggest players in the
german book industry huganduba talia and
weld build are hoping this device will
help them face the challenges posed by
digitization
two years ago these book selling giants
all faced massive profit losses
they were forced to close branches and
lay off employees
but then the booksellers pulled together
to launch an e-reader
you see us here today standing together
but if you'd seen us two or three years
ago we would have behaved differently
toward one another
at the time the circumstances were more
confrontational but now we understand
that the world has changed and we have
to adapt
the patterns of the past no longer fit
the future
and the future is truly digital
in germany as in the rest of the world
bookstores are becoming less popular as
people increasingly buy books online
the german book industry's e-reader is
called tolino
it costs about 100 euros
we hope to create a counterbalance to
amazon on the german market we also want
to defend and expand the market segments
we have in the traditional book business
the whole book market is undergoing such
an upheaval that the tolina cooperation
is probably only the beginning of a new
kind of partnership in the industry
it would be great if we could come
together and stand up to amazon and
other external actors
the tolino has already netted a market
share of about 40 percent it's almost on
par with amazon's e-reader
customers tend to be older people who
like to read a lot
you can download the books you want to
read on holiday and it's really easy
otherwise you'd have to lug around three
or four kilos
there are currently about 2 million
books in the tolino system in contrast
to amazon's ebook system customers can
decide which bookstore they want to buy
their books from
uncomfortable
it's all about the approach and we
believe our customers like being free to
choose which is why we built an open
system from the start
customers can decide what to download
what to get rid of and where to buy a
book
this philosophy is fundamentally opposed
to that of american competitors on the
global market which have closed systems
our system corresponds to the way of
thinking in germany
and customers are beginning to
appreciate this advantage
the booksellers teamed up with deutsche
telekom which developed the tolino
device and the cloud from which users
can download books
small teams produced the operating
system and designed the cases which are
manufactured in taiwan
but otherwise it's a product made in
germany
made in germany made in germany means
creating a sustainable product creating
stability and a feeling of trust and
competence it's not enough to shop
around for hardware in china and simply
buy something
you really have to think about what the
average customer might want
there's a nice story to how the tolino
success began
the main target group is women over 40.
the most popular book is shades of grey
erotic literature
some don't want others to see what
they're reading so they go for ebooks it
was this
when women buy things they look at the
material
the color they take pleasure in buying
this
thing
deutsche telekom has released four
different versions of the tolino since
march
and now they're looking further afield
and we'll be announcing our first
international partnership in a few days
the first outside of germany but there
will be more maybe even this year
because we have to make sure we have an
international product
this will benefit the bookstores
involved as they will earn their share
on the export of the tolina product
but as nina huguen double insists it's
still the book itself that's most
important
there are printed books like here
electronic books we can't see
audiobooks and um
there's a massive array of books here
the biggest range is on the internet but
here people can look around flick
through
many readers in germany may still share
this view
but the popularity of ebooks is on the
rise
you